so amy is great to have you here tonight
with the premiere they came together
tell me about your role in a movie I
play Molly the female lead the romantic
comedy klutzy plucky small business
owner who runs a candy shop and falls in
love with Joel played by Paul red you
guys have worked together before how did
it compare okay let's move Paul and I am
I have never done a film together we did
wet hot American summer together but um
and we did some television together in
parks and rec but this is the first film
we've done together it was really fun it
was great and of course the director
writers were Michael shorter David Wain
what's it like working with those guys
well I've had a pleasure of knowing
David and Michael for so long now and I
just love working with them it feels
like family a little bit and the film
was like really fast we shot in like 22
days think that it was like a million
bucks or something so we worked really
hard and it was a group effort for sure
um but but this is David Wayne's baby
and he he put this together in a in a
really special way how did you guys come
on both in we had done or we were at a
sketch festival having a wet hot reunion
and we did a reading of the script and
Paul and I were like this is so funny we
should try to do this and then many
months later we got to do it which was
really cool now if you say that one
thing that makes this movie stand out
what would it be it's really done in the
best way it's really really stupid is
that the kind of comedy that really
appeals to you I mean I just I'd mean
that as the highest compliment it's one
of the stupidest movies I've ever
and I I think people that enjoy comedy
will understand what I mean when I say
that it's really good Oh communit
forward to you from your neck statement
um tonight I'm gonna meet me put this
evening or oh um i'm gonna do i'm at
aunt woman i'm working on am woman yeah
it's theresa's awkward exclusive you're
playing ant man that meant i'm like a
you auntie auntie auntie man and aunt
aunt woman some people do not seem to
say aunt man aunt man yeah when they're
being particularly pretentious
you